[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen Sven FOS hat den Sport
für sie unter anderem mit den deutschen
Handballern guten Abend und auf diese
Themen schauen wir auch ausführlich in
dieser
Sendung Kampf ums Rote Meer mit
Luftschlägen attackieren Amerikaner und
Briten im Yemen die Husi Rebellen diese
wollen weiter Handelsschiffe
angreifen die CDU und der rechte Rand
beim Geheimtreffen rechtsextremer Kreise
waren auch CDU Mitglieder die Partei
kündigt harte Konsequenzen
an gdlstik und kein Ende nach dre Tagen
Stillstand auf der Schiene wie geht es
weiter im Tarifstreit zwischen
lockführern und
Bahn als Reaktion auf Angriffe der huthi
Rebellen auf Schiffe im Roten Meer haben
die USA groß Britannien und Verbündete
Stellungen der huthis im Jemen
bombardiert zudem plant offenbar die
Europäische Union ein Militäreinsatz im
Roten Meer zum Schutz der
Handelsschiffahrt auch Deutschland
könnte sich beteiligen laut Auswärtigem
Amt in der Nacht griffen Kampfjets und
Kriegsschiffe rund ein Dutzend
Militärstützpunkte im Jemen an die huthi
Miliz kontrolliert große Teile des
Landes sie wird vom Iran unterstützt und
solidarisiert sich mit der
radikalislamischen ham im Gazastreifen
seit Ende November attackieren die
Rebellen immer wieder Handelsschiffe im
Roten Meer Benjamin
Daniel unter anderem von diesem
Flugzeugträger aus starten die USA und
ihre Verbündeten ihre Angriffe gegen
hutistellungen konkret attackieren sie
Waffenlager luftabwehranlagen und
Marinestützpunkte überraschend kommt das
für viele
nicht die internationale Gemeinschaft
hat die htis mehrfach gewarnt und jetzt
haben wir unseren Worten Taten folgen
lassen trotzdem werden wir alles dafür
tun dass der Konflikt zwischen Israel
und der Hamas in Gaza nicht zu noch mehr
Eskalation in der Region
führt auch die Bundesregierung stehe
hinter den Angriffen erklärt
Außenministerin berbock während ihrer
malaisierreise die husis gefährden durch
ihre Angriffe rücksichtslos
Menschenleben sie tragen damit zur
Destabilisierung einer schon
angespannten regionalen Lage
bei seit Ausbruch des Krieges zwischen
Israel und der Hamas greifen huti
Rebellen immer wieder Schiffe mit
angeblich israelischer Verbindung im
Roten Meer an sowohl die Hamas als auch
die huti Rebellen werden von Iran
unterstützt für das Weiße Haus aber kein
Grund für noch mehr
Eskalation wir suchen keinen Konflikt
mit Iran es gibt auch keinen Grund für
eine Eskalation die über das hinausgeht
was in den letzten Tagen passiert ist
und die Eskalation ging ja auch von den
hutis
aus die huti Rebellen bezeichnen die
militärschläger als Terrorismus und
drohen mit Vergeltung im Jemen
protestieren 10ta000ende gegen die
Angriffe was im Roten Meer passiert ist
wirtschaftlich besonders wichtig der
mehr als 10% des Welthandels laufen über
diese Meerenge wegen der Angriffe der HU
die Rebellen nehmen die meisten
Containerschiffe jetzt einen Umweg in
Kauf und fahren lieber um Südafrika
herum das dauert aber etwa zwei Wochen
länger als die Abkürzung durch das Rote
Meer Christoph desterell berichtet hutti
Rebellen ker in ein Handelsschiff und
Filmen sich dabei selbst ende November
war das spätestens da erkennen die
rädereien der Welt die für sie so
wichtige Route rotes Meer ist riskant
geworden gerade aus deutscher Sicht auch
wirtschaftlich ein Problem die Schiffe
bräuchten dringend militärischen Schutz
fordern die hiesigen Räder und das
ausdrücklich auch von der Regierung in
Berlin Deutschland hat sehr große
Interessen die durch den Sueskanal durch
das Rote Meer gehen 60% des Import und
exportvumens in Deutschland ist
seegestützt und da erwarten wir
natürlich dass Deutschland seiner
Verantwortung gerecht wird seit November
nahmen schon gut 2000 Schiffe zur
Sicherheit den Umweg vor Bayern
Südafrika mit Folgen kostete ein
Container von Asien nach Europa Anfang
November etwa 1500 $ so sind es jetzt
4000 es mag für die Räder also auch um
Geld gehen vor allem aber um Planbarkeit
was brüchige Lieferketten bedeuten er
fährt gerade Tesla mit seiner Fabrik in
Brandenburg und meldet wegen fehlender
Bauteile sei man zwischen dem 29 januar
und 11 Februar dazu gezwungen die
Fahrzeugfertigung mit Ausnahme einiger
weniger Teilbereiche ruhen zu lassen die
noch gute Nachricht auf Warenangebot
oder Preise in Deutschland schlägt die
Krise im Roten Meer erstmal nicht durch
denn nungef ein Drittel unserer Ausgaben
verwenden wir auf Importe ungefähr 10 %
unserer Importe und Export te kommen aus
China 15% aus Asien das heißt 15% von
30% und dann da gibt's nch eine kleine
Änderung im Preis das wird der
Verbraucher am Ende gar nicht so
wirklich merken erst wenn die hoties
auch Öl oder Gastanker angreifen würden
könnte es wirtschaftlich kritisch werden
und weitere Hintergründe zur schwierigen
Lage im nadelö rotes Meer ab 19:30 Uhr
bei ZDF heute live unter anderem mit
einem Fachmann für maritime Sicherheit
zu finden auf unserer Homepage und in
der
App israel hat sich vor dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof in den HA
gegen den Vorwurf des Völkermordes
verteidigt einer der israelischen
Anwälte kritisierte die von Südafrika
erhobene Klage als haltlos und absurd
israel sei im Krieg mit der Hamas nicht
mit dem palästinensischen Volk die
Angriffe im Gazastreifen seien durch das
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
gedeckt an einem Treffen mit neonat in
Potzdam haben neben AFD Politikern auch
mindestens zwei Mitglieder der CDU
teilgenommen gegen ein Mitglied hat ein
CDU Kreisverband in Nordrheinwestfalen
jetzt ein Parteiausschlussverfahren
eingeleitet die CDU will sich stärker
von der extremen Rechten abgrenzen die
Einzelheiten von Matis
Feldhoff es ist ein Politikwechsel den
die ziduda plant die bisherige Ansprache
von AFD Wählern als proteststimme soll
der Vergangenheit angehören müsse jedem
sagen wen er da wählt was die AFD vorhat
mit ihren rechtsextremistischen und
radikalen Vorfeldorganisation ist auch
ein Umsturz dieses Landes dieser
Demokratie Auslöser ist eine
geheimkonferenz im letzten November bei
der AFD Politiker unter anderen ein
Vertrauter von Alis Weidel mit
rechtsextremen über eine millionenfache
Vertreibung von Migranten
diskutierten mit dabei auch mindestens
zwei CDU Mitglieder aus
nordrwestfalen denen droht der
Parteiausschluss wir werden hart und
konsequent daruf reagieren
deputationsfantasien in diesen Zeiten
auszuleben habe ich persönlich als sehr
krass empfunden und widerspricht der
freiheitlichen Grundordnung unseres
Landes umstritten in der CDU ob das für
ein AFD Verbot spricht das NPD Verfahren
gebe wenig Hoffnung das
Verfassungsgericht hat im letzten
Verbotsverfahren den Satz in das Urteil
reingeschrieben es kann Parteien nicht
abnehmen sich um die Wähler zu bemühen
ein weiterer Fall macht heute die Runde
der ehemalige CDU Finanzsenator von
Berlin Peter Kurt soll privat den AFD EU
Spitzenkandidaten Krah sowie mehrere
rechtsextreme empfangen haben Kurt ist
auch Präsidiumsmitglied des BDI
industriepräsident Russwurm distanziert
sich von ihm wer jetzt in dieser
Demokratie in Deutschland nicht aufwacht
und eben weiß dass es 55 Uhr ist und wir
jetzt gemeinsam kämpfen müssen den kann
ich auch nicht nicht weiterhelfen es ist
eine kehtwende der CDU das Wahljahr 2024
wirft seinen Schatten
voraus und bei mir im Studio ist jetzt
Matthias vornauf mit dem aktuellen ZDF
Politbarometer guten Abend Matthias
hallo guten Abend wie schneiden die
Parteien zur Zeit ab ja das schauen wir
uns jetzt genau an wenn am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre dann käme die SPD
auf 13 % -1 neuer Tiefstwert seit
Regierungsantritt CDU CSU
31%-1 grüne 14 FDP
4-1 AFD
22%. linke 4 freie Wähler 4 + 1 BSW
4%. 20% wären das für Parteien die es
nicht in den Bundestag schaffen dadurch
würde es reichen für schwarzgrün und für
schwarzrot das
bündniswagenknecht hat Potenzial über
die 4% hinaus ich würde das BSW wählen
das Sagen 4% weitere 17% aber sagen sie
würden das Bündnis wahrscheinlich wähen
27% wahrscheinlich nicht
47% auf keinen Fall gerade gibt es ja
Proteste von Bäuerinnen und Bauern sowie
ein Arbeitskampf bei der Bahn wie kommt
das bei den Befragten an ja wir schauen
mal wie viel Verständnis gibt's für den
Streik der Lockführer 43% haben
Verständnis dafür eine Mehrheit von
54% aber
nicht Kürzungen in der Landwirtschaft
stehen die Befragten eher kritisch
gegenüber und zeigen Verständnis für die
Proteste nur 12% finden es sollte so
gekürzt werden wie ursprünglich geplant
32% finden die jetzige Planung richtig
und 52% sagen es sollte überhaupt nicht
gekürzt werden die Haltung zu den
Protesten 30% ging das zu weit 68% aber
zeigen Verständnis danke schön für die
Zahlen
Matthias und das gesamte ZDF
Politbarometer können Sie im heute
journal sehen unter Unmut der Landwirte
und LandwirtInnen über die Sparpläne der
Bundesregierung geht weiter Schwerpunkt
heute an Tag 5 der Proteste war unter
anderem Bayern an einer Sternfahrt nach
Nürnberg beteiligten sich nach Angaben
der Polizei knapp 5000 Menschen auf der
anschließenden Großdemo sprach auch
Bayerns Ministerpräsident Söder er
forderte die Bundesregierung auf sich
bei den Bauern zu
entschuldigen im März wird in Russland
ein neuer Präsident gewählt mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit wird der neue
Präsident wieder Wladimir Putin heißen
es wäre seine fünfte Amtszeit es gibt
aber Menschen die trotz geringer Chancen
gegen ihn antreten wollen einer davon
ist Baris nadjestin der 60-Jährige
ehemalige dumer Abgeordnete gilt als
eine der letzten kritischen Stimmen im
Land immer wieder hat er sich gegen den
Krieg in der der Ukraine positioniert
nun hat sich nadestin der Presse
präsentiert gemeinsam mit Ehefrauen von
Soldaten Amin Körper berichtet
nadda ist die Hoffnung auf Russisch und
Paris Nadin gibt sich als
Hoffnungsträger der Opposition gestern
Abend
Wahlkampfveranstaltung er will Präsident
werden vor allem die spezialoperation
beenden und stellt die ganz offen in
Frage warum kann er das seit Z Jahren
sage ich im russischen Fernsehen dass
die spezialoperation ein Fehler Putins
ist wie Sie sehen bin ich frei und nicht
als ausländischer Agent eingestuft ich
weiß auch nicht
warum und dann auch noch das nadtin hat
die Frauen mobilisierter Soldaten
eingeladen seit Monaten fordern die die
Rückehr ihrer Männer und damit den
Kremmel
heraus am 13 Dezember hatte mich das
letzte mal angerufen danach kam nichts
mehr vor Silvester erfuhr ich dass er
verletzt wurde und machte mich auf die e
ich habe ihn in einem Krankenhaus
gefunden 14 Tage Urlaub von der Front
das ist ein Schlag ins Gesicht für alle
Familien der mobilisierten vom
Präsidenten ich habe keine Angst das zu
sagen und Baris nadestin offenbar auch
nicht wir wollen einfach dass die Männer
zurückkommen und ehrlich gesagt will ich
dass das alles ganz schnell
aufhört eine Veranstaltung der
Opposition ganz ohne Sicherheitskräfte
allein das ist bemerkenswert und lässt
vermuten dass niadestins Kandidatur eine
von kremmels knnaden sein könnte um der
Präsidentschaftswahl den Anschein von
fairnness zu geben doch dafür muss Paris
nadestin noch eine Hürde nehmen bis Ende
des Monats braucht er 100.000
Unterschriften dann könnte ihn der
Kremmel zur Wahl
zulassen und auch Taiwan steht vor
Präsidentschaftswahlen und das bereits
morgen knapp 20 Millionen
Wahlberechtigte sind aufgerufen ihre
Stimme abzugeben das wichtigste Thema
ist der Umgang mit dem übermächtigen
kommunistischen Nachbarn China der sieht
den kleinemokratischen Inselstaat als
abtrünige Provinz und rot offen damit
die Wiedervereinigung zu erzwingen aus
taip berichtet Miriam
Steimer Flugzeuge beobachten das ist
danielos Hobby Taiwans Himmel ist dafür
gerade ein guter
beim Fotografieren vor 10 Jahren habe
ich nur selten ein Militärflugzeug
gesehen da musste man echt Glück haben
vor allem die zur Luftverteidigung mit
angehängten Bomben die konnte man nur
ein zweimal im Monat sehen jetzt fast
jeden
Tag Taiwans Militär will vorbereitet
sein denn der mächtige Nachbar China
lässt rund um die demokratische Insel
immer wieder die Muskeln
spielen in seiner Neujahrsrede sprach
stat und parteichfin Ping gerade von der
historisch unvermeidbaren
Wiedervereinigung China favorisiert
einen Machtwechsel zur Peking
freundlicheren KMT doch nach den letzten
Umfragen liegt eher vorne William lei
von der regierenden Fortschrittspartei
Peking bezeichnet ihn als gefährlichen
Separatisten und Unruhestifter und hat
die Wahlen zu Schicksalswahl erklärt für
die Menschen hier sei es die
Entscheidung zwischen Krieg und
Frieden das Thema dominiert den
Wahlkampf
wenn Festland China uns angreift wohin
sollen wir fliehen wenn es so kommt
können wir es nicht
ändern ich ma mir Sorgen dass meine
Familie verletzt wird es keinen
Unterricht gibt und nicht genug zu
essen vor allem jungen Leuten kommen
andere Themen zu kurz z.B dass taip
Immobilienpreise zu den höchsten der
Welt gehören mit durchschnittslöhnen
unbezahlbar viele unterstützen einen
dritten Kandidaten der ein Ende der
hohen Wohnungspreise
verspricht
zurück nach Deutschland seit heute 18
Uhr ist der Bahnstreik vorüber nach dre
Tagen und wie geht's nun weiter die Bahn
will ab morgen früh wieder normal fahren
im Tarifstreit mit der Gewerkschaft GDL
bewegt sich allerdings nicht viel und so
stellt GDL Chef weselski schon den
nächsten Streik in Aussicht der sei
unvermeidlich wenn die Bahn den
lockführerinnen und Lockführer nicht
entgegenkomme hansjür Piel
berichtet schon kurz nach 18 Uhr fuhren
die sbahnen eder fast wie gewohnt im
Fernverkehr gilt der Ersatzfahrplan aber
vorerst weiter erst morgen sollen die
Züge hier wieder normal fahren auch drei
Tage lockführerstreik haben keine
Annäherung gebracht GDL Kundgebung in
Magdeburg der nächste Ausstand könnte
schon bald kommen nach Abschluss dieser
streikmaßnahme lassen wir dem
Unternehmen ein Stück weit Zeit um zur
Besinnung zu kommen tun sie das nicht
wird die nächste Arbeitskampfmaßnahme
folgen sie wird bestimmt länger sein und
sie wird Kunden noch Herter treffen
Knackpunkt bleibt weiter die
Arbeitszeitverkürzung die GDL fordert
eine 35 Stundenwoche mit vollem
Lohnausgleich für Schichtarbeiter die
Bahn will die Wochenarbeitszeit nur
gegen anteiligen Verzicht auf
Gehaltserhöhungen verkürzen forderte
heute erneut eine Rückkehr an den
Verhandlungstisch es ist jetzt auch an
der GDL wieder an diesen Tisch
zurückzukehren zu streiken um alle
Forderungen durchzusetzen so
funktionieren Tarifverhandlungen nicht
während die Mehrheit aller Personenzüge
im Streik ausfiel waren es im
Güterverkehr höchstens 40% weil den
Großteil der Fracht längst Privatbahnen
transportieren und die kamen
streikbedingt sogar besser ans Ziel
unsere Unternehmen haben es leichter auf
dem vollen Netz weil weniger Züge
unterwegs sind sie kommen pünktlicher an
und das ist natürlich auch noch ein
Punkt weswegen keine Lieferketten
zusammenbrechen bei Deutschlands
zweitgrößte Bahnunternehmen transdeev
ging der Streik schon heute Mittag zu
Ende hier ist man inzwischen bereit über
eine 3 Stunden Woche bei vollem
Lohnausgleich zu
verhandeln seit Tagen herrscht vor allem
in der Nordhälfte Deutschlands strenger
Frost wenn dazu noch Regen fällt gibt
das eine gefährliche Mischung auf der
A72 bei Kemnitz rutschte ein LKW durch
die Glätte von der
Fahrbahn bei zahlreichen Unfällen wie
hier bei Neuwied wurden mehrere Menschen
verletzt die Polizei ruft weiterhin zu
äußerster Vorsicht
auf und der Sport beginnt mit den
Eiskunstlauf Europameisterschaften s ja
und da waren die Hoffnungen groß beim
besten deutschen paar Hase volodin mit
einem aussichtsreichen Platz z war das
du ins Kürfinale eingezogen doch der
Traum von einer Medaille ist nun
geplatzt der Trainer mag es nicht mit
ansehen zwei grobe Patzer Kosten den
Podiumsplatz zunächst stürzt Minerva
Fabian Hase beim dreifachen Wurf
ritberger wenig später misslink die
geforderte Hebung Nikita volodin muss
sie abbrechen seit einem Jahr laufen die
beiden zusammen der Hype war nach einer
Siegesserie groß der Russe volodin
besitzt noch keinen deutschen Pass damit
wäre derzeit kein olympiastart möglich
die fehlerhafte Kü lässt Hase volodin
auf Platz 5 Abstürzen es siegt das
italienische Duo bekari guarise vor
einem georgischen und einem weiteren
italienischen paar das zweite deutsche
Duo Annika Hocke Robert Kunkel belegt
Rang
7 wir bleiben auf dem Eis Olympiasieger
Christopher grot hat beim ersten
skeleton Weltcup des Jahres Platz Z
geholt auf der Natureisbahn von St
Mauritz musste sich Groer nur dem
Italiener Amedeo bnis geschlagen geben
auch in der Gesamtwertung liegt der
Thüringer nach vier von A Rennen auf
Platz
2 und nach dem begeisternden Sieg der
deutschen Handballer im Eröffnungsspiel
geht der Blick längst in Richtung
nordmazedonien gewinnt das deutsche Team
erneut wäre das Minimalziel bereits
erreicht em
Hauptrunde das dhbteam im Training mit
Spaß und selbstbewus sein denn im
auftaktsspiel lief vor allem dank
Torhüter Wolf schon vieles richtig gut
es war war sowohl Andy der überragend
war als auch eine wahnsinnig bewegliche
und trotzdem kompakte Abwehr das wäre
natürlich schön wenn wir daraus noch
mehr einfache Tore werfen nordmazedonien
der vermeintlich leichteste
Vorrundengegner aber sie haben sehr sehr
viele offensivvarianten die sie spielen
können in der Abwehr kommen Sie über
über
Heißblütigkeit das Rezept kühlen Kopf
bewahren und taktisch ans schweizspiel
anknüpfen vor den Augen auch von Kanzler
Scholz der Sonntag in der Berliner Arena
sein wird tja kühlerkopf fällt im Moment
nicht leicht ne bzw nicht
schwer stimmt danke S und wir haben noch
Neuigkeiten von einer echten
architektuurrikone der Brooklyn Bridge
in New York das 140 Jahre alte Bauwerk
erdacht vom deutschstämmigen Ingenieur
Johann Röbling ist jetzt auch nachts ein
echter Blickfang zusätzlich zu den
vorhandenen Lichterketten erstrahlen nun
auch die ten backsteintürme dank
ledcheinwerfern von weitther sichtbar
die Brooklyn Bridge über die jeden Tag
alleine rund 120 000 Fahrzeuge fahren
wird seit vier Jahren umfassend
renoviert trübe und winterliche
Aussichten für das Wochenende kommen
gleich von Katja hornifer sie erklärt
ihn aber auch wo sie dennoch die Sonne
sehen können das heute journal läuft an
diesem Abend gegen 22:45 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend die Sonne konnten sie heute
z.B hier im Harz sehen aber auch im
Bayerischen Wald im Schwarzwald und auf
der Schwäbischen Alp sonst dominierte
Hochnebel und hohe Wolken zogen noch
über den Hochnebel hinweg es gab
Nieselregen Schneegriesel und genau
damit haben wir es auch noch in der
Nacht zu tun besonders hier im Nordosten
und in der Mitte Deutschlands da sollten
Sie sich nach wie vor auf Glätte
einstellen auf Straßen und Gehwegen in
Süddeutschland ist es zum Teil klar dann
bildet sich Bodennebel und auch dort
kann es dann reif glatt werden wenn der
Nebel am gefrorenen Boden festfriert und
am Alpenrand wird es bitter kalt mit
-13° + 5° sind es auf den Ostfriesischen
Inseln die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen zwischen -2 und 7° und das wird
für die meisten von uns eher ein
trübertag weiterhin mit Schnee
Schneegriesel Schneeregen und
Nieselregen es bleibt also glatt auf
Straßen und Gehwegen auch wenn sich die
Glätte im Laufe des Tages mehr in die
Mittelgebirge zurückzieht an der
Nordseeküste rupft der böige Westwind
die Wolken auch mal auseinander und auch
zwischen dem oberrein und dem allgu
werden sie die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen
ganz ähnlich sieht es dann auch am
Sonntag aus guten Abend